NATO's secretary
general, Jens Stoltenberg,
live from Brussels.
Secretary General,
thank you for being here
on what is becoming a very impor
in these announcements
coming from the United States
and NATO's allies.
What is your reaction
to these tank announcements?
How big of a moment
is this at the moment?
These are important announcement
And what
Chancellor Schultz,
the German chancellor, said toda
really is important
because it makes it possible for
Germany, but also for other Euro
allies to provide
a little prod to battle tanks to
and that will significantly stre
their combat capabilities.
And it demonstrates also
the unity and the resolve of NAT
in the partners in providing sup
to Ukraine.
Secretary General,
the introduction of tanks has lo
been discussed.
What did it take to get here?
What you have seen
is that
the front lines
in Ukraine has stabilized,
and we have seen how the Russian
digging in
and and are building fortificati
So
if we want Ukraine to be able
both to defend
against the upcoming Russian off
so we know that the Russians are
for new offenses.
And also,
if you want Ukraine to be able
to retake the territory,
we need to give them more armor,
more heavy and modern weapons.
And therefore, I welcome the U.S
leadership and the announcement
that was made last week
of armored personnel
carriers, of infantry fighting v
and now the announcements of bat
that all together
will strengthen significantly
the strength to combat
the strength of
the Ukrainian armed forces
and we need that to ensure that
President Putin doesn't win this
There has been a view
that what NATO allies have provi
this point
has been enough
to keep Ukraine in the fight,
but not enough for you,
Ukraine, to win this war.
I have heard that
from retired
generals, military experts
for quite some time.
Do you think the introduction
of these tanks finally provides
the capability to actually win
so NATO's allies and
partners have provided unprecede
level of support
to Ukraine since the start of th
And actually many allies,
including the United States,
trained and supported the Ukrain
before the invasion.
We have done that since 2014.
And this has enabled them
to push the Russian forces out
first of
the territory in the north aroun
then in the east, around Kharkiv
and then in the south
against a heartsong.
Now we see that
the Russian of the Russians,
President Putin, has mobilized
more than 200,000 more troops
there are ramping up production
of ammunition, weapons
and they are planning a new offe
So then we need to
provide even more support
not only to ensure that Ukraine
survives but acts to ensure that
is able to liberate more territo
and win
and prevail as a sovereign,
independent nation in Ukraine.
And that's exactly what NATO all
are doing with the announcements
we saw last week.
But also with the announcement
of battle tanks today,
I'm hearing from some military
experts already,
secretary general,
that the number of tanks
all put together.
And while it's not entirely know
what the total amount will be,
but the scope of
what is being promised in terms
that it is still inadequate
for what Ukraine needs.
What do you say to that?
So, first
of all, I
will leave it to individual alli
to make the
specific announcements.
But the German announcement
today is important
and not least also
because it opens up for
other European allies
that have leopard tanks to provi
a leopard thanks to Ukraine.
And there are many European alli
that have leopard tanks.
And many of them have made it cl
that they are ready to provide
battle tanks to to Ukraine.
And I spoke just
now with President Zelensky,
and of course, he welcomed
the announcement
made not only from Germany,
but also from many other allies
to provide tanks,
but also provide training, ammun
maintenance, spare parts,
the whole logistical support
for these new heavy, modern NATO
standard battle tanks.
Russia's response today
is that these tanks, quote,
will burn just like all the othe
What is your
message to Russia today?
Ukrainians
have proven extremely skilled an
in operating the equipment,
the weapons
need to allies and partners have
absolutely certain that
they will able to do that.
Also with the
main battle
tanks from NATO's allied countri
especially because
many of them
have a lot of experience already
in from the frontlines
operating Soviet era
armored vehicles, battle tanks.
But of course,
that is a useful background
when they then start training on
and NATO's battle tanks
We have to remember what this is
This is a war of aggression.
President Putin
invading another sovereign,
independent nation in Europe, Uk
Ukraine, has the right for self-
and we have the right to support
in upholding that right.
Because
if President Putin wins, it's
a tragedy for Ukrainians.
But it's a little dangerous for
because the message
is that when authoritarian leade
use military power,
they get what they want
and then the world
becomes even more dangerous
and we are more vulnerable.
Therefore, it is in our security
to support the Ukrainians.
Secretary General Jens Stoltenbe
thank you so much for coming on
to react to all of these announc
happening today.
I sincerely appreciate it. Thank